The web is always changing
and the way we access it is changing.
The source of that change is you:
developers all around the world who are
using our tools to create great new things
and with so many tools, the sky's the limit.
But it can't happen without you and your ideas.
We want to know you better so we created a
new place
just for that -- to hear from you.
We want to hear what inspires you as a developer
and how we can help.
Here you can record a video, share stories
with us, and more.
Let us know what being a Google Developer
means to you.
And you can talk to us in person at Google
Developer
events all over the world so that we can learn
how to support you better.
Oh, by the way, we also started rolling out
a new
site for Google Developers. Not just code,
but community,
news, tools, and other resources. And cake.
Like any open source project, it's a work
in progress.
With your help, it can be great.
developers.google.com/stories
Change is important to the web. Help us keep
changing it
together.